-You guys,
tomorrow is Thanksgiving.
So I'm happy you're here.
Thank you very much.
I love Thanksgiving.
It's fun spending the day
looking at passed-out relative
and trying to guess
"Full, high, or drunk?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Thanksgiving is almost here.
Tomorrow, you'll be
patting, rubbing,
and stuffing your turkey,
while today, the TSA
did all of that to you.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey!
-Even though it's Thanksgiving
tomorrow you can still go
to Applebee's, Boston Market
and Denny's.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's perfect if you just realize
something not working,
like your oven, your stove
or your marriage.
[ Laughter ]
I saw that storms
are already wreaking havoc
across the country.
And the Northwest is getting hit
with a bomb cyclone.
[ Audience "ooh"s ]
Sounds like something
your uncle says
as he runs to the bathroom
on Thanksgiving,
like, "Look out, Jimmy!
There's about to be
a bomb cyclone!"
[ Laughter ]
Why do you walk like that?
"Hey, where's the bathroom
I don't know -- Where is it?
[ Laughter ]
Why -- Stop walking like that.
-"Ohh!"
-"I need some paper towels!"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Bird, bird, bird ♪♪
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The Northwest --
Why are you walking like that?
-Why?
-I don't know, man.
I think you'd be like -- I don't
know who'd be walking that
[ Laughter ]
[ Fart ]
Oh, hey.
[ Laughter ]
-That was not me.
That was not me.
[ Blows raspberry ]
That was me.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't do
that type of humor here.
-No, we don't appreciate that.
-That's right. The Northwest
is dealing with a bomb cyclone
featuring 100-mile-per-hou
winds, rain, and snow.
So it looks like winter
and your in-laws
showed up earlier
than you wanted.
It's like, "Um, Dad,
it's 10:00 in the morning.
What's up?"
"You said to be here.
There's no traffic.
Couldn't believe it."
[ Laughter ]
"You're seven hours early.
"I'll help you with --"
"No, I don't want it. Okay."
Yeah, thanks to
the awful weather,
thousands of flights
across the country
have been delayed or canceled.
I'm not saying
the airports were crowded,
but this is what happened
any time an outlet opened up
No, it's unbelievable --
It was like --
[ Laughter ]
Not only are flights a mes
right now,
but people who are driving
for Thanksgiving
are having a rough time, too
Take a look at the traffic
last night in Los Angeles.
-It's about 53 minutes
from L.A.X.
to the 405 and Sunset Boulevard.
If you were riding a bicycle
it would take you about an hour.
So, it's almost
just about as fast
to take the freeway
with a bicycle.
[ Laughter ]
-Meanwhile, the guy on the bik
breathing in fumes
was like, "Yeah,
this is the way to go.
This is -- I feel great."
[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter ]
Last night, President Trump held
a rally in Sunrise, Florida,
and he called
the impeachment inquiry a scam
a terrible hoax,
and a witch hunt.
People in the crowd were like,
"Looks like we're getting
leftovers before Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
During the rally,
Trump talked about his
unscheduled trip to the hospital
but he made it a little weird.
-They said,
"He went into the hospital."
And it's true.
I didn't wear a tie.
Why would I wear a tie
if the first thing they do i
say, "Take off your shirt, sir
and show us
that gorgeous chest"?
[ All groaning ]
-Republicans in Congress heard
and were like,
"Even we can't back you on thi
one." That was like -- Yeah.
What was happening?
Was his teeth falling out?
-I think his teeth
were falling out a little bit.
[ Stammering ]
-[ Lisping ] "I went to the --
I went to the doctor."
[ Stammering ]
He's trying to stick it back u
with his teeth.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Can we hear that again?
Dave, is --
-They said,
"He went into the hospital."
And it's true.
I didn't wear a tie.
Why would I wear a tie..."
-"Wear a tie. Tie."
-...if the first thing
they do is say,
"Take off your shirt, sir,
and show us that
gorgeous chest"?
-[ Slurring ] "Show us
that gorgeous chest."
[ Both stammering ]
"I'm Carol Channing."
♪♪ Hello, Dolly ♪♪
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, this morning,
Trump tweeted out
a picture of his head --
This is real.
[ Laughter ]
We can all agree this is
really happening. Right?
-He did this.
-Trump tweeted out a picture
of his head on Rocky's body.
Take a look.
This is what he tweeted.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Yeah. Clap now, but you know
that's going to be
the new $20 bill.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Lisping ]
"Gorgeous chest.
Do you have change
for a $20 bill, please?
Did you see my gorgeous chest?
[ Laughter ]
-"Ooh, I gotta go do
a bomb cyclone."
-"You wouldn't wear a tie.
[ Stammering ] Tie."
[ Laughter ]
Want to see my gorgeous chest?
He's turning into Uncle Jesse.
-Yeah.
-"You want to see it, huh?
[ Laughter ]
Let me see that Rocky phot
one more time, too.
See, that's how you feel
before Thanksgiving dinner
and here's how you feel
after Thanksgiving dinner.
You know what I'm saying?
-Oh!
-For real.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Why?
-[ Grunting ]
-"Ohh, my chest."
[ Laughter ]
-But Trump is currently
at Mar-a-Lago
to celebrate Thanksgiving.
-Oh.
-He's actually excited
about the holiday,
'cause this year, Eric and Don
Jr. are gonna pull the wishbone,
and loser takes the fall
for Ukraine.
-Aww.
-It's really cute.
Speaking of Trump,
out of all the 2020 candidates
President Trump has the most
followers on Instagram
with 15.4 million.
That's 12 million more tha
any of the other candidates.
Trump's Twitter
gets all the attention,
but his Instagram account
is actually very interesting
Check out
some of his recent posts.
For example, first Trump wrote
"Looking forward
to spending Thanksgiving
with my loved ones."
He posted a photo
of the host of "Fox & Friends.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Next Trump wrote,
"I'm so proud to introduce
my new ambassador to Iceland."
He posted a photo
of Olaf from "Frozen."
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Trump wrote,
"I'm gonna tell my kids
this was Chris Hemsworth,"
and posted a photo of Don Jr
-Oh, why?
-What is this kid?
And finally Trump wrote, "Yo
can't pardon all the turkeys,"
and posted a photo
of Rudy Giuliani, so...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some 2020 Democratic candidate
have announced
their Thanksgiving plans.
Pete Buttigieg
is going deer hunting.
Kamala Harris will be cheering
on runners at a turkey trot.
And Bernie Sanders
will tell his family
what the pilgrims were lik
at the first Thanksgiving.
-Oh.
[ Audience groaning, laughing
-Next week,
Democrats will start draftin
articles of impeachment
against Trump.
This is very nice. They're gonna
deliver the articles
with one of those giant red bows
you see in a Lexus commercial.
-Aww.
-[ Lisping ]
You see in a Lexus --
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you guys,
the holiday shopping seaso
is about to kick off.
And I saw that
for the first time in years,
Toys "R" Us
is opening new stores.
Yep. But when you go inside --
When you go inside, it's jus
one laptop connected to Amazon
[ Laughter ]
Finally, I saw that
for Black Friday,
23andMe is offering
50% off DNA tests.
That's how you know
you had a rough Thanksgiving
with the family
when the first thing you buy
is a DNA test to prove
you're not related.